who wants an open border where people
from mental institutions are being
dumped into the U.S where people from
prisons where entire prison populations
of countries are being and I do the same
thing if I was the president of a South
American or not only South American
they're coming from all over the world
he may not know the names of any South
American countries which is why he
paused like that they're dumping their
prison population into the United States
of America they're dumping their people
from mental institutions and words that
aren't used anymore insane asylum did
you ever hear you're too young that's
where Silence of the Lamb of course
that's the lamb you know it's it's
Silence of the Lambs right where Silence
of the Lamb happens to be uh you know
what's represented but insane asylums
these These are seriously sick they are
being dumped into the United States of
America huge massive dumps they're not
happening though that's that's untrue it
isn't happening